وهو النظام الامريكي
بلبراليه والنظام الصيني يعني النظام
الصين الصين نهضت باتفاق 1972 اللي هو
صناعه امريكيه وفتحت الجامعات فلاحظت
الصين بينماو وكيسينجر ونيكسون ثم جاء
دونك وبدا التطور الصناعي هذا النموذج
اللي امامك الان اللي هو اقتصاد السوق
الاشتراكي طبيعه الحكم نقلت 300 مليون من
الفقر الى الغناء في الصين فهذا طبيعه هذا
النظامة هذه النظام الحكم لا تستطيع ان
تطبقها الحزب الشيوعي الواحد في الولايات
المتحده فدائما حسب طبيعه يعني انت لا
تستطيع ان تعيد الملكيه الى تونس لانه
انتهت عهد الملكات لانه الملكات في العالم
العربي كما ذكرتكم سابقا اذا هي ناشئه من
فئه وهذه دول محدوده يعني الدول الخليج
والاردن والمغرب خارج هذا الاطار فرضا
وبالتالي لا نظام الشارع لم يكن ملك هو
رضا ميرنجي سايسخير اتى هذه الدوله
القاجريه ثم تحول العسكري رئيس الوزراء ثم
انقلب والبس نظام موه لبوس الملكيه ولم
يكن النظام بدليل هذا النظام كان عاجز على
الاستمرار لو لم يعاد بعد ثوره مصدق
بالجبر
الولايات المتحده فهذه تعتبر طبيعه مثلا
تونس اول دوله فيما يسمى الثوره حكم
التاثير ما يسمى الربيع العربي الان
المشاركه التونسيه في الانتخابات وصلت 11%
بينما كانت وصلت الى 40% بالبدايه فانت لا
تستطيع لا يوجد في السياسه والاقتصاد نص
ونظام مقدس يعتمد على طبيعه كما قال موتو
يعتمد على الجغرافيا والمناخ والعادات
والتقنيه